let's start with something that's still  kind of depressing but at least a little  funny in some sense from the New York  Post quote she was 12 I was 30. Biden  leaves viewers stunned in teacher's  speech uh correction to your post the  crowd cheers for him he laughed loudly  they laughed loudly in the high it's  very funny when a guy makes a joke about  that's a that's a that's a very large  age Gap you've got there they say  President Biden shocked viewers on his  Friday speech teachers when he  recognized an audience member and told  the crowd she was 12 and I was 30.  abiding lit up social media with the  confounding and seemingly inappropriate  aside he did not say what he did when he  was 30 and the wind was a pre-teen you  got to say hi to me Biden said  mid-speech at the National Education  Association headquarters in DC we go we  go back a long way she was 12 and I was  30. but anyway this woman helped me get  an awful lot done huh as a 12 year old